what's going on guys if you're here you
probably saw Nick Mundy's other video
where he messes around with WWE
Superstars if you haven't seen it click
right here so anyway this video Nick
what do you got in store for us more of
me embarrassing myself in front of
people I admire oh I see you do that all
the time yeah it's kind of my thing
enjoy I could be a manager for you if
you wanted like a like your backup yeah
can you give me an example of what what
you could do like okay why does Daniel
Bryan deserve be in the main event of
Wrestlemania okay Dana Brad deserves to
be WrestleMania cos he's the best
wrestler ever and he's the best
technical wrestler he's the best at
wrestle he's the best on the mic he has
red hair he has red beard he's just a
good dude
he gave me a compliment we need to
appeal to the casual fan so how are you
going to appeal make me appeal to the
case okay sell the people on it
listen dummies by the pay-per-view this
guy's awesome
just do it that was really good now
screen junkies we you should be watching
wrestling because this gentleman right
here is a real-life superhero you're a
real-life action star aren't you yeah
that's the best compliment smartest
thing you've said all day and yeah yeah
I got glue yeah you're you're really
sweaty no I'm sorry it's hot and then
that's why at the band dance I'm not
sweating at all it's not that warm
you got WrestleMania coming up it's a
big week and you are competing in the
Andre the Giant battle royal memorial
battle royal
oh that's rude the Andre the Giant
memorial battle royal makes we got to
get a right product placement know that
stuff you know wwe's wrestlemania Andre
the Giant memorial battle royal
featuring my good friend Xavier woods
there you go perfect
see I'm not terrible at this uh no I was
just like I don't shut up to him you've
been wrestling for like 15 since 1999
right 15 years you started in my home
state San Antonio Texas uh-huh San
Antonio is a city but yes did I grow up
Texas I should know the better guy
what's your favorite superhero God uh
Iron Man yeah Robert you would be a
great when Robert Downey jr. Lee
yet you'd be a great you would you'd be
just a great friend don't push it okay
I'm the greatest person like in the
world pretty much athlete intelligent
good-looking great hair look at that
body
right right look look at it no touch
don't touch
merchandise you're competing in
WrestleMania yes I am the Andre the
Giant memorial battle royal second
annual and you get a big trophy right
yeah big trophy and go next my internet
title in my office okay and then and
then that will finally show my dad
what's that when you win they'll finally
show my dad
oh so Mon I got a friend who's a winner
oh cool now we have the show called
movie fights and I think you would be an
amazing competitor you you're you have a
grasp on pop culture I got my finger on
the pulse yeah so we have Dan Merle the
guy back they are like going no this is
going terrible's happened um he's of the
movie fight champion and we bring him on
with this belt so I can see it firsthand
oh that's cute
now you're real can I can I see it is it
okay
I like this you know what I want to
compete on movie fights and take out Dan
I want this Dan this this title I know
it means everything to you it's your
world it's your rock but I'm gonna come
under your show and I'm going to
absolutely destroy you destroy your
strike do we get to pick I didn't know
the rules do we pick the movie that we
argue for we'll do it for you you can
pick whatever movie you want whatever
moving going with the movie white chicks
Dan looks like a white chick ah looking
like a white chick ah where's your twin
sister white chick idiot yeah dummy and
then if you want to go two out of three
second movie that I'll pick is a goofy
movie goofy you can't hang with me and
then if you want to go three rounds
three out of five I'll go hackers Oh
what is that a 56k modem and then
Angelina Jolie's like oh I'm so hot with
short hair but nobody knows about me
exciting Tomb Raider movies on the Reg
I'm taking this championship from you
give me a fight give me a fight so you
were real man it's like that's rocky
what up screen junkie fans
this guy is a pure athlete a pure star
and he is literally going to fight five
other men with the ladder eat it Robert
Downey jr.
eat it action stars how are you gonna
fight the ladders and and everyone else
are you gonna fight everyone at the
ladder
were you uh you just quoting Weird Al
and eat it just now I wasn't listening
anything if it makes you like me more oh
then you weren't okay I think I'll
interviews on a little too long it's
co-ed at this right
I hope stop it down are we thank you so
much I know I'm really nervous
alright alright well Nick that was fun
but I gotta admit your interview skills
were a little bit rough did the rest of
screen junkies have any reaction to that
yeah actually uh they're sending me meet
the cast of Furious 7 next week my
schedules pretty wide open next week
thanks for watching I'm Hal rod Nick
Keys Nick Mundy hit us up on Twitter bye
so we've established that you need to be
silent you need to be a boy that you're
stupid that you sweat too much you
should wear depends for your whole body
and you need to shut up think you just
cut a promo on